[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا في هذه النشره من العربيه معكم
راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه اذا 360 الخبر
من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه نبدا بابرز
يتنادى
بعد تدمير سد نوفاكوفا موسكو وكاف
تتبادلان الاتهامات وتحذران من كارثه
ومجلس الامن يدرس
الملف السودان يحافظ على مسريه المفاوضات
غير المباشره تعود في جده والاشتباكات
تتجدد في العاصمه
باريس ولندن وبرلين تلوم طهران على تازم
ملف برنامجها النووي وتؤكد انه تجاوز
المبررات المدنيه
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
بنزيما
3 سنوات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قعدت الحرب الاوكرانيه تحولت
قضيه تدمير جسر نوفا كخوفكا الى ماده
جديده لتبادل الاتهامات بين موسكو واكياف
اغلقت المياه ومناطق واسعه في اوكرانيا
التي باتت تتحدث عن اكبر كارثه من نوعها
في اوروبا منذ عقود اختلف الغريمان حول
كيفيه تدمير السد وما اذا كان استهدف
بصاروخ او لغم من داخله لكنهما وبلهجه
الواثق دعايا مجلس الامن لمناقشه الهجوم
[موسيقى]
اذا اتهم الرئيس
الاوكرانيسيا بتفجير محطه كخوفكا لطاقه
الكهرومائيه من داخل المنشاه معتبرا انه
يستحيل استهدافها بصاروخ من
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه لسوء الحظ كانت روسيا تسيطر على
هذا السد منذ اكثر من عام ومحطتك للطاقه
الكهرومائيه باكملها ومن المستحيل جسديا
نصفها بطريقه ما من الخارج بالقصف تم
تعدينها تم تلغيمها من قبل المحتلين الروس
وقاموا بتفجيرها
وعلى الجانب الاخر وفي مقابله مع العربيه
وصف السفير الروسي لدى فيينا ميخائيل
اوليانوف اتهام بلاده باستهداف المنشات
النوويه بالامر السخيفه
لا يحتاج الامر للتاكيد على ان كل الجهود
ستبدل لضمان الامن النووي والحديث بان
روسيا تعرض المنشات النوويه للخطر هو امر
سخيف نحن اسسنا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه وبالطبع دائما ما نتعاون مع
الوكاله ونتوقع ان تتعاون الوكاله معنا
وهذا التعاون يحصل بصوره دوريه ومن ضمنها
حول منشاه زابوريا
حدث وضرب سد نوفاكخوفكا في منطقه خيرسون
جنوبيه اوكرانيا ويحدث ايضا ان المياه
تغمر ما في طريقها وفي طريقها تتبادل
موسكو الاتهامات
الرئيس الاوكراني سارع الى القاء اللوم في
الهجوم على من وصفهم بالارهابيين الروس
ودعا الى طرد روسيا من اوكرانيا
واتهمت القياده الجنوبيه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه بتفجير السد
مدير مكتب الرئاسه الاوكراني اعتبر تدمير
السد جريمه حرب جديده وتشكل تهديدا لمحطه
زبروجيا النوويه وتهديد الاف السكان جنوبي
خرسون اما عمده مدينه نوفاكا خوفكا
الموالي لروسيا اتهم القوات الاوكرانيه
بقصف السد في المدينه فيما رجحت السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا ان القصف تم
براجمات صواريخ لكن من المستفيد يقول
الجيش الاوكراني ان هدف روسيا من استهداف
السد هو تعطيل العمليات الهجوميه بزياده
منسوب نهر دنيبرو ما يصعب العبور للضفه
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في حين يقول
الكرملين ان اوكرانيا تعمدت استهداف السد
لقطع امدادات المياه عن شبه جزيره القرم
والتغطيه على فشل هجماتها المضاده الاخيره
وفيما فتحت روسيا تحقيقا جنائيا بعد
انفجار سد نوفا كخوفكا دعت اوكرانيا مجلس
الامن الدولي الى اجتماع طارئ بشان ذلك
ايضا
[موسيقى]
ومن ابو ظبي ينضم الينا عبر زوم فيتالي
فيديانيين الدبلوماسي الاوكراني اهلا بك
سيد فديانين يعني اتهامات متبادله بين
روسيا واوكرانيا حول الجهه التي دمرت اسد
ما الذي يجعل العالم برايك يصدق الروايه
الاوكرانيه خاصه وبانه للمصادفه اليوم
الواشنطن بوست تحدثت عن احتماليه تورط
اياد اوكرانيه في تفجير نور ستريم
اولا
اليوم قام الاتحاد الروسي بالعمل الارهابي
وركبت جريمه الاباضه البيئيه
بهدف بالتسبب في اكبر عدد ممكن من الضحايا
والدمار في اوكرانيا وكمان المهم ان بحسب
القوانين الدوليه وبالتحديد اتفاقيه جنيف
يعد تدمير صدور جريمه حرب
تسوس استخدام الاسلحه الدمار الشامل يعني
اليوم استخدمت روسيا ضد اوكرانيا اسلحه
دمار الشعب وعلى العالم تعامل مع هذه
الكارثه
المناسبه
فنحن ندعو المجتمع الدولي الى اذانه
بشده التفجيراني الروسي وليس فقط الى
الاداره ولكن كمان الى اتخاذ اجراءات
اللازمه لهزيمه النظام المسكوي
الارهابي يعني
تتحدث ولكن هناك روايه روسيه بالمقابل
هناك اتهامات من الكرملين بانه يمكن ان
يكون هدف اوكرانيا هو تعطيش القرن يعني
لماذا تنفون احتماليه ان يكون يعني هناك
جهات ربما غير رسميه اوكرانيه وراء تدمير
السد يعني لماذا لا تضعوها كاحتماليه
لان من المستحيل عمليا تفجير المحطه من
الخارج بقصف مدفعيه او بضرب يعني
هذا من بديهيات ان عند تصميم وانشاء مرافق
المهمه للبنيه التحتيه الحيويه مثل
المفاعيل النوويه او صدور مثل سد الكخوك
ياخذ مهندسون في الاعتبار مخاطر ضربات
الخارجيه يعني وحتى يعني الضربات العسكريه
مثل الضربات المدفاعيه وضربات لماذا الان
لماذا دمرت روسيا
نستخدم يعني بانفسنا اخوك لتزويدنا
بالمياه واليوم نحن كنا نتابع طوابير
طويله لشراء مياه الشرب في مدينه
الرئيس الاوكراني ونحن نستخدم هذا يعني
بانفسنا
سنناقش معك نقطه ما سيناقشه ويناقشه مجلس
الامن الليله اي ملف الهجوم على سد
نوفاكا بعد طلب من اوكرانيا التي دعت كذلك
مجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الى
مناقشه الحادث وطالبت بفرض عقوبات جديده
على روسيا فيما يتعلق بصناعه الصواريخ
والقطاع النووي
وكان مدير عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفيان جراثي قال انه ليس هناك خطر
نووي في محطه حتى الان مؤكدا ان خبراء
الوكاله يتابعون الوضع عن كثب
تقييمنا الحالي هو انه لا يوجد خطر مباشر
على السلامه المصنع نتابع هذا كل دقيقه تم
ابلاغ موظفي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بالموقع بان الاضرار التي لحقت بسد
نوفا تؤدي حاليا الى انخفاض يصل الى خمسه
سنتيمترات في الساعه في ارتفاع الخزان
يواصل الفريق مراقبت هذا المعدل وجميع
الامور الاخرى على الموقع
من جديد السيد فيتالي من ابوظبي يعني هناك
اجتماع لمجلس الامن حول هذا السد ومن وراء
ما الذي تتوقعونه من هذه الجلسه في ظل
امتلاك روسيا وايضا الصين حق الفيتو الذي
يعرقل اي قرار
اهم شيء نحن نحتاج الى اجراءات عمليه
لهزيمه نظام المستوى الارهابي عن طريق
الرفع
الضغط وعن طريق يعني فرض العقوبات
الاضافيه وخاصه على صناعات الصواريخ
والصناعه النوويه الروسيه وكمان يعني
تزويت اوكرانيا بالكميه المناسبه من
الاسلحه لطرد
الاحتلال الروسي ويعني ضحر الاحتلال وطرد
من اوكرانيا يعني بطريقه النهائيه لان لا
يجوز يعني ترك هذا العمل الارهابي دون
العقاء كما قلت اليوم مستخدم روسيا اسلحه
دمار الشامل ضد الاوكرانيا
وسيؤدي الافلات روسيا من العقاب اليوم الى
المزيد من الجرائم الوحشيه اذا على العامل
التعامل بالطريقه المناسبه والعمليه ضد
هذه الجريمه الوحشيه
من جهتكم كيف ستتعاملون مع هذه كما
تسمونها الجريمه التي وصفتها منذ قليل
بانها جريمه حرب وكذلك وصفها
رئيس الاوكراني لانها منشاه مدنيه خدميه
هل ستقدمون مثلا ملف الى مجلس الامن غير
هذه الجلسه يعني بما ان جريمه حرب هكذا
تصفونها
ربما ولكنني اهم شيء نحن نتوقع اسراء في
تزويت اوكرانيا بالمساعدات العسكريه
المطلوبه
لان يعني كل ما اسرعت شركائنا في تزويدنا
بالاسلحه كلما
اسرعت يعني نهايه هذه الحرب العدوانيه
الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك من
ابوظبي فيتالي فديانيين الدبلوماسي
الاوكراني شكرا
سد النوفاك خوفكا يقع على نهر دنيترو على
مسافه 30 كيلومترا من مدينه خرسون بني في
عام
يعد جزءا من محطه كخوفكال هيدروكهربائيه
ارتفاعه يبلغ 30 مترا
يحتوي خزانه على 18 كيلو مترا مكعبا من
المياه سيطر عليه الروس مع بدايه الحرب في
فبراير 2022
اهميته تكمن في انه يمد شبه جزيره القرم
وجنوبي اوكرانيا بالمياه
ومياهه ضروريه لتبريد محطه زابوريجيا
النوويه
الهجوم على السد مرتبط بحسب اتهامات
كيافوا موسكو بتطورات العمليات الميدانيه
لذا وصف وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجو تفجير
ساد نوفا كخوفكا بالعمل الارهابي الذي
دبرته اوكرانيا مشيرا الى انها بدات بناء
دفاعات في الضفه اليمنى لنهر النبرو على
حد قوله كما اوضح
هجمات على مواقع مختلفه بالخطوط الاماميه
منذ ثلاثه ايام مضيفا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه نفذت هجمات في خمسه اتجاهات
الاحد الماضي وكلها باءت بالفشل واشار
الوزير الروسي الى ان 71 جنديا من القوات
الروسيه لقوا حتفهم في اليومين الماضيين
عدا عن تدمير خمسه عشره دبابه وتسع مدرعات
روسيه خلال التصدي لهجمات اوكرانيه والان
زيلينسكي يقول بانه بحثت مع مدير الطاقه
الذريه هذا عمليه تدمير هذا السد
الهدف من هذا التفجير حسب المعطيات
المتوفره ما يلي بعد فشل العدو في تحقيق
نجاح في العمليات الهجوميه يعتزم العدو من
اجل تعزيز امكاناته نقل الوحدات والمعدات
من محور خيرسون الى منطقه العمليات
الهجوميه مما سيضعف مواقعه على محور خرسون
الى حد كبير
[موسيقى]
تم التدريب تسعه منها من قبل النيتو بمجرد
اكتشاف اي فجوه في دفاعات روسيا وان تكون
الهجمات المتقطعه مقدمه للهجوم المضاده من
الهجمات الاوكرانيه ما تم شنه باستخدام
اسلحه قدمها الغرب نتحدث طبعا عن الهجوم
بصواريخ ستورم شادو البريطانيه على مراكز
لوجستيه وايضا مراكز قياده خلف خطوط
الجبهه ايضا تحدثت مصادر عسكريه روسيه عن
رصد دباباتي
ومدرعات فرنسيه في ساحه المعركه ما يشير
الى انضمام القوات التي دربها الناتو الى
الخطوط الاماميه لاول مره منذ بدء هذه
الحرب كما رصدت اقمار صناعيه عسكريه
امريكيه ارتفاعا طفيفا في الضربات
المدفعيه وايضا في الهجمات البريه من
المواقع الاوكرانيه من الجانب الاخر
مشاهدينا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
احبط ت هجوما واسعا النطاق من ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتين للدبابات جنوب دانياسك
الناطق باسم الوزاره ايغور كوناشينكوف قال
ان القوات الاوكرانيه حاولت اختراق مع
اعتبرته اكياف الجزء الاكثر ضعفا في
الجبهه الا ان الهجوم لم ينجح بحسب قوله
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا لكن بعد الفاصل بعد تعثر
مفاوضاتها مع صندوق النقد روما تمد يد
العون لتونس ب 700 مليون يورو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قناه وكاله بلومبرج ان
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يخطط لزياره
الصين خلال اسابيع وانه قد يلتقي الرئيس
تشيت جنبينغ وكان بلينغ الغى في فبراير
الماضي زياره مماثله بعد حادثه المنطاد
الذي اتهمت واشنطن بارساله للاجواء
الامريكيه للتجسس
عده فرنسا اعتراضها على خطه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي الافتتاح مكتب للحلف بالعاصمه
اليابانيه طوكيو لمنع تصعد التوتر بين
اوروبا والصين الرئيس الفرنسي اما نيويورك
ارجع اعتراض بلاده على المقترح لاعتقاده
بان التوسيع الحلف لنفوذه خارج مناطقه
سيكون خطا كبيرا وقد يزيد التصعيد مع
الصين ويتطلب انشاء مكتب للنيت ودعما
بالاجماع من مجلس شمال الاطلسي وهو اعلى
هيئه لصنع القرار السياسيه في التحالف مما
يعني ان فرنسا لديها القدره على وقف هذه
الخطوه ولدا الناتو اكثر من عشره مكاتب
اتصال او ممثليات حول العالم الا ان
معظمها صغير ومصمم للمساعده في الاتصال
بحكومه البلد المضيفي والجيش المحلي
وها هي تاثيرات الحرف في اوكرانيا تصل
للقطب الشمالي المتجمد مع قلق من محاولات
روسيا والصين زياده نفوذهما في المنطقه
مجلس القطب الشمالي قطع العلاقات مع روسيا
العضو في المجلس ما يزيد خطر وجود منطقه
قطبيه دون قواعد خاصه اذا انشات روسيا
والصين مجلسا موازيا خاصه بهما للقطب
الشمالي المجلس يضم في عضويته اضافه
لروسيا كلا من الولايات المتحده كندا
ايسلندا النرويج السويد فنلندا والدنمارك
التي تتبع لها جزيره
لكن بعيدا عن الجانب السياسي لنتحدث عن
الاهميه الاقتصاديه للقطب الشمالي هذه
المنطقه رغم انها متجمده الا انها تصنف
بانها الاكثر ارتفاعا في درجات الحراره في
العالم ويفتح الباب وراء الاهتمام
بمواردها وايضا بث الموارد غير المكتشفه
تقدر بتريليونات الدولارات فهناك
30% من الاحتياط العالمي للغاز وخمسه عشر
في المئه من احتياط النفط غير المكتشف
عالميا اضافه لكميات كبيره من الالماس
والنيكل والزنك وعناصر نادره تدخل في
الصناعات العسكريه وخلال العقود الاربعه
الماضيه تقلصت مساحه الجليد في هذا القطب
بنسبه 35 في المئه ويتوقع العلماء ان
يخلوا القطب من الجليد بحلول عام 2050 بحد
اقصى طبعا ذوبان الجليد سيكشف عن ممرات
مائيه للشحن البحري تختصر المسافات بين
قارات اسيا واوروبا وايضا امريكا الشماليه
كما ان الذوبان سيجعل عمليات التنقيب
ممكنه وهنا يطرح التساؤل من له الحق
باستغلال موارد القطب الشمالي طبعا الدول
المطله على هذا القطب لها قانونيا حق
الاستغلال الاقتصادي للمنطقه الخاصه بها
وهي دول المجلس القطبي الا ان الاجزاء
الاخرى البعيده في القطب فلا ملكيه ولا
سياده لاحد عليها نختم من حيث بدانا مع
غياب الملكيه والسياده ونضيف اليهما غياب
القواعد ربما تكون هذه النقطه المتجمده
احدى اسخن بؤر التوتر في العالم مستقبله
[موسيقى]
كشفت مصادر العربيه عن عوده المحادثات غير
المباشره بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع بتسهيل من السعوديه وامريكا في
مدينه جده وتركز اجنده المفاوضات على
الترتيبات الانسانيه ووقف اطلاق النار
كمنخرط كل وفد في اجتماعات منفصله مع
مسهلي عمليه الحوار واوضحت مصادر العربيه
انه لم يتم طرح اجنده جديده في هذه الجوله
في الاثناء افاد مراسل العربيه باندلاع
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في الكلاكله بالخرطوم وكانت الليله
الماضيه شهدت قصفا بالمدفعيه الثقيله
والطيران الحربي واطلاق نار متقطع جنوبا
مع تحليقا للمقاتلات هذا وتعرضت احياء شرق
الخرطوم امس لقصف عنيف بالمدفعيه والطيران
بحسب شهود عيانات في حين ابلغ سكان في
محيط مقر قياده الجيش بتعرض عدد من
المنازل لقصف عشوائي استمر حتى فجر اليوم
يعيش اقليم دارفور او ضاع الماساويه بسبب
القتال الدائري في السودان الامر الذي دفع
حاكم الاقليم ميني اركو ميناوي الى اعلان
دارفور منطقه منقوبه تحتاج للمساعدات
بعد اكثر من 50 يوما من القتال في السودان
لحقت باقليم دارفور اضرار عديده تمثلت في
اللجوء والتشريد لعدد كبير من المواطنين
بهذا الاقليم حاكم اقليم دارفور مني اركب
الناوي اعلن بان اقليم دارفور يحتاج
لمساعدات عاجله وبان هذه المنطقه من
السودان تعتبر منطقه منكوبه لذلك تحتاج
الى التدخلات العاجله في اقرب وقت
والله بن طالب ومن ناشد المنظمات
الانسانيه والخيريه انها تجينا راجعه زي
ما قالوا تقدم يد العون لانه في ناس عانت
بجد بالذات في موسم الخريف ده ونحن بالوف
عندنا في شهر 9 وشهر خمسه واربعه والفصول
والغريب دي يعني في بيكون ركود اقتصادي
صعب جدا يعني المنظمات دي بتسهل مساهمه
كبيره لو بتساعد في هالمشاكل كثير من
البيوت يعني والله القتال هو الداير بين
الجيش والدعم السريع خلف نزوحا كبيرا
باغلى بدارفور فقد تضررت مراكز ايواء خاصه
بالنازحين بغرب دارفور تضرر معسكر نيفاشا
وكساب بشمال دارفور كمناطق يصعب ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه اليها مع ما تشهده من
قتال يومي وانعدام في السلع الاساسيه
وتحول الصراع في بعض المناطق بهذا الاقليم
الى صراع الكل ضد الكل مما خلف جرائم
كثيره جدا وتعتبر
كارثيه بالنسبه للانسان الان المويه
الواحد يمشي بيت في او يجيب صف من الصباح
لحد الازر عشان يجيب برميل بدامواه وينتهي
اليوم الثاني يعني معاناه لدرجه اكثر من
كده وبعدين
الماكل والمشرب في ناس كثير حيكون شغال
رزق اليوم باليوم في السوق والاسواق هم
شغاله والله الاسعار دي مبالغه فيها يعني
اسعار يوميا يعني في اليوم ممكن يزيد حاجه
مرتين عندك البرميل
يعني فتره السبعه هي لما بقينا الفتره
النسائيه بيجوا الصباح ب 500
يعني شوف اسعار غيالي كما امتداد رقعه
الصراع لتشمل مناطق من جنوب دارفور وايضا
محليات تتبع لشمال دارفور من ضمنها محليه
كتم الصراع وايضا اثر على حركه الطرق بين
المدن المختلفه هنا في اقليم دارفور كما
انه ساهم مساهمه كبيره في عدم ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه من بورسودان الى
دارفور صالح ابو علامه اقناعيه العربيه
والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان
[موسيقى]
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه التزامه
واشنطن بتعزيز شاركتها الامنيه مع
السعوديه بمفاذك بما في ذلك المبيعات
الدفاعيه والتدريبات المشتركه ومكافحه
انتشار الصواريخ والطيران المسير لدى جهات
غير حكوميه وقبيله زيارات وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي قالت الوزاره ان التعاون مع
السعوديه من اجل ضمان الاستقرار الاقليمي
يظل احدى ركائز علاقتنا الثنائيه واضافت
ان الشراكه الامنيه في البلدين او بينهما
قائمه على الاهتمام المشتركي بامن منطقه
الخليج ومنع اي قوه اجنبيه او اقليميه من
تهديد المنطقه
العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه
ثمانيه عقود من الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
السعوديه وامريكا
بحسب بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه فان
السعوديه والولايات المتحده تجمعهما علاقه
استراتيجيه ممتده لاكثر من ثمانين عاما
حيث يعد العمل على ضمان الامن الاقليمي
احد اسس العلاقه مع الرياض
وتعزز العلاقه مع الرياض امن الخليج
والقدره على ردع اي تهديد لامن المنطقه
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان هناك التزاما
بتعزيز الشراكه الامنيه مع الرياض عبر دعم
البنيه الدفاعيه الجويه والتدريبات
المشتركه وتعمل السعوديه والولايات
المتحده على حل ازمه السودان وحمايه
المدنيين وتمكين وصول المساعدات كما دعمت
السعوديه الجهود التي قامت بها الامم
المتحده في خفض التصعيد واحلال السلام في
اليمن
ورحبت الولايات المتحده بالخطوات التي
اتخذتها السعوديه لدعم اوكرانيا بما في
ذلك التعهد بتقديم مساعدات بقيمه 400
مليون دولار
هذا ووصل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بليكن الى السعوديه حيث سيبحث مع مسؤولين
سعوديين تعاون الاستراتيجيه الامريكي
السعودي في القضايا الاقليميه والعالميه
ومجموعه من القضايا الثنائيه بما في ذلك
التعامل الاقتصادي والامني وافاد مراسل
العربيه ان زياره بلينكن ستستغرق يومين
حيث سيشارك في اجتماع وزري لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي الامريكي لمناقشه التعاون المشترك
وتعزيز الامن والاستقرار وخفض التصعيد
وتكامل الاقليمي والفرص الاقتصاديه في
جميع انحاء الشرق الاوسط كما سيحضر بلينكل
مع وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اجتماعا وزاريا للتحالف الدولي
لهزيمه داعش في الرياض لتوصليه الضوء على
الدور الحاسم الذي يلعبه التحالف لمواجهه
التهديد المستمر لدعشه
وكان كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي جيم ريتش
دعا اداره الرئيس جو بايدن الى تعزيز
العلاقات مع السعوديه باعتبارها شركه مهما
اقتصاديا وامنيا لواشنطن وقال ريتش على
تويتر انه على مدى ثمن عاما كانت السعوديه
شريكا مهما في دعم المصالح الامنيه
والاقتصاديه المشتركه مشيرا الى ان اداره
بايدن تاخرت في تعزيز التعاون مع المملكه
فتحت السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض ابوابها
بحضور مساعد وزير الخارجيه السعودي للشؤون
القنصليه علي اليوسف ونظيره الايراني
اضافه الى القائم بالاعمال الايراني في
السعوديه حسن زنكار وشمال الاحتفال رفع
العلم الايراني في السفاره وعدد من
الكلمات للمسؤولين الايرانيين وحضر
الاحتفال اعضاء السلك الدبلوماسي في
السعوديه منذ الخليجيه وعربيه وغربيه
اعاده الافتتاح تاتي بعد ثلاثه اشهر من
توقيع الاتفاق السعودي الايراني لاستئناف
العلاقات بينهما برعايه صينيه
وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد حسن
القائم باعمال السفاره الايرانيه في
الرياضه ان اعاده افتتاح السفاره امر
ايجابي مؤكدا على ضروره عوده العلاقات لما
له من منفعه اقتصاديه وتجاريه للبلدين
وللمنطقه
[موسيقى]
عوده العلاقات بين الدولتين السعوديه
وايران ضروريه للمنطقه نرى ان عوده
العلاقات الضروريه ومستقبل العلاقات
بينهما مشرق وسيتم توسيع العلاقات
التجاريه والاقتصاديه والسياحيه المتبادله
بين البلدين وبشكل عام عوده العلاقات امر
ايجابي ويعود بالنفع على المنطقه اجمعها
فرضت الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات جديده
تستهدف شبكه من سبعه افراد وسته كيانات في
ايران والصين وهونج كونج لدعمهما لبرامج
صاروخيه وعسكريه ايرانيه واضافت الخزانه
في بيان ان العقوبات تشمل الملحق الدفاعي
الايراني في بكينه واوضحت ان الشبكات تسهل
معاملات ماليه وشراء اجهزه متطوره حساسه
لجهات فاعله في تطوير الصواريخ الباليستيه
الايرانيه واكدت الوزاره مواصله استهداف
شبكه
المشتريات غير المشروعه الداعمه لانتاج
ايران للصواريخ الباليستيه والبرامج
العسكريه الاخرى
افاد بيان فرنسي الماني بريطاني مشترك بان
تقرير المدير العام لوكاله الطاقه الذريه
يظهر ان ايران تواصل السير على طريق
التصعيد النووي مضيفا انها تواصل تطوير
برنامجها النووي بصوره تتجاوز المبررات
المدنيه لاسيما وان اجمالي مخزونها من
اليورانيوم المخصب وصل الى اكثر من 21 ضعف
من الحد الذي نص عليه الاتفاق النووي حيث
انها ما تزال تركب مجموعات اضافيه من
اجهزه الطرد المركزي المتقدمه لتحسين
قدرات التخصيب مما يجعل اتفاق النووي بلا
قيمه ووفق البيان الثلاثي فان ايران تتحمل
المسؤوليه الكامله عن الوضع الحالي ويجب
عليها التوقف الفوري عن تصعيدها النووي
واكد البيان التزام الدول الثلاث باتخاذ
كل الخطوات الدبلوماسيه لمنع ايران من
تطوير اسلحه نوويه
[موسيقى]
الى الكويت حيث اغلقت صناديق الاقتراع
الانتخابات مجلس الامه
2023 في نحو 118 مركزا ويتنافس في هذه
الانتخابات 207 مرشحين
ومرشحه وهو العدد الاقل منذ عام 2008 ويحق
لقرابه
794 الف ناخب وناخب الادلاب باصواتهم
لمرشح واحد فقط
ومن الكويت تنضم الينا مراسلات العربيه
شهد المتروك اهلا بك الشاهد يعني حجم
الاقبال كيف يمكن وصفه والترجيحات هي
لصالح من
نعم يعني قبل قليل او قبل اكثر من ساعتين
قرابه ساعتين ونصف تقريبا تم اغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع وبدات عمليه فرز الاصوات للاعلان
عن نتائج الانتخابات والاعلان عن اسماء 50
مرشح يفوز بمقعد في البرلمان الكويتي
وتحديدا في قاعه عبد الله السالم طبعا لا
توجد الى الان اين نتائج رسميه ما زال
عمليه او ما زالت عمليه الفرز او مستمره
هناك نسب اوليه لنسبه المشاركه يعني بحسب
المحللين والمختصين وايضا المراقبين
الانتخابين نسبه او اعلى نسبه مشاركه ربما
توجد في الدائره الثانيه بحسب مره اخرى
يعني الرصد الاولي لهذه
المشاركه اقل نسبه ربما جاءت في الدائره
الخامسه بواقع
49% من اجمالي عدد الناخبين في تلك الد
لدينا خمس دوائر مجموع عدد الناخبين فيها
في الخمس دوائر قرابه 794 الف ناخب وناخبه
ربما الاقبال على المشاركه يعتبر نسبيا
ضعيف بسبب يعني حاله الاحباط التي يعني
يشعر بها الناخبون والناخبات يعني بسبب
قرب الوقت الزمني ما بين الانتخابات
تعلمين الانتخابات الماضيه التي عقدت في
2022 لم تكمل السته اشهر وبعدها حكمت
المحكمه الدستوريه ببطلان المجلس ويعني
وعوده مجلس 2000 وبعدها تم حله واليوم
دعوه للناخرين بالتصويت مره اخرى
والتصويت لمجلس جديد هناك طبعا ايضا نتائج
اوليه لاسماء المرشحين في الدوائر لكن هذه
الاسماء ايضا غير ثابته الى اعلانها رسميا
من قبل القضاه في اللجان الاصليه والفرعيه
شاهد بما انه تحدثتي عن المترشحين ما سبب
انخفاض عدد هؤلاء في هذه الانتخابات
تحديدا
يعني عدد مرشحين يعني لا يمكن يعني ذكر
سبب معين يعني ربما قرب الوقت ما بين
الانتخابات الماضيه وهذه الانتخابات لم
يعني يشجع الكثير بالمشاركه في سواء
الترشح او حتى التصويت كما ذكرت نسبه
المشاركه تقريبا اكثر بقليل من خمسين
بالمئه اكثر من قليل من نصف عدد
الناخبين ايضا كان هناك يعني خجل ملحوظ
بمشاركه المراه في الترشح لانتخابات مجلس
الامه لدينا ثلاثه عشر امراه فقط شاركت في
سباق انتخابات مجلس الامه املا في الفوز
ايضا بمقعد في البرلمان الى الان ربما
يوجد اسم امراه واحده تتصدر في الدائره
الثانيه لكن مره اخرى لا يمكن يعني رسميا
الاعلان عن هذا الاسم لان الفرز او عمليه
الفرز ما زالت مستمره شكرا جزيلا لك سنكون
طبعا معك
عندما يعني يستجد اي جديد من الكويت
مراسلات العربيه شهد المتروك
قناه رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
ميلوني ان بلادها ستضخ 700 مليون يورو في
تونس لدعم القطاعات الحياتيه ذات الاولويه
وعقب اجتماعها مع الرئيس قيس سعيد اكدت
ميلوني انه يجب انتاج مقاربه واقعيه تمكن
تونس من الحصول على فرص للتمويل الدولي
وكان الرئيس قيس السعيد رفض شروط من سنود
صندوق النقد الدولي للاقراض على اعتبار
انها تهدد السلم الاجتماعي
في الكوارث سيهتم اغلب الناس بانتشال
الذهب لكن قد ينتشر احدهم قلما تابعونا
بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ادلى الامير هاري نجل
الملك تشارلز الثالث بشهادته في المحكمه
حول اتهاماته بشان خرق ناشر صحيفه مرير
خصوصيتها وهذه اول افاده لاحد اعضاء
العائله المالكه في المحكمه ليس كشاهد
فحسب بل ايضا كصاحب دعوه لمقاضره صحيفه
تغطيه اعلاميه كبيره لمعركه الامير هاري
القضائيه ضد ناشر صحيفه ديليمر وادعاء خرق
خصوصيته في حمله لفضح مخالفات الصحافه
الشعبيه البريطانيه من اجل انقاذها كمهنه
وفق زعمه
الامير هاري هو اول افراد العائله الملكه
بشهادته في المحكمه منذ 130 عاما وبعد
اداء القسم استهل محامي دفاعي مجموعه
الصحف ميرور اندروغرين بسؤال الامير هاري
فيما يتعلق مقالات قال انها تستند الى
مواد تم الحصول عليها بشكل غير قانوني
اعداءه للصحافه كان واضحا في الرد على
اسئله هيئه الدفاع الصحيفه من رمي اللوم
عليها في الحاجه التي اودت بحياه والدته
ديانا الى معاناه من اضطراب مع عائلته
واصدقائه من خلال جمع معلومات لمقالتها عن
طريق الخداع وانشطه غير مشروعه متسائلا عن
علاقه اموره الشخصيه بالمصلحه العامه التي
شكلت كيف ينظر اليه من قبل عامه الناس
شاهدا فحسب بل انه ايضا المدعي في هذه
القضيه وما يجعلها محاكمه ضخمه انه احد
افراد العائله الملكه وابن الملك تشارلز
يخوض معركه قضائيه ضد احد اكبر ناشر الصحف
بريطانيا
يوم ثاني من التدقيق في مضمون ادعاءات
الامرهري مبرمجا في جلسه المحاكمه
التاريخيه لكن قرار الحكم النهائي في
قضيته سيتطلب سنوات لقناتي العربيه والحدث
مصطفى
العربيه عروض بعض الحق اهلا بك عروب يعني
ما هي ابرز مجريات محاكمه اليوم وهل من
ردود فعل ان كان من القصر او حتى الناس
على هذه المحاكمه
مرحبا راويه طبعا المساله الاساسيه الان
هي ما اذا كان الامير هاري سيكون قادر على
توفير ادله على الادعاءات التي قال يعني
الادعاءات التي اتهم بها مجموعه مرر للنشر
والتي قال بانها استخدمت طرق غير قانونيه
للحصول على معلومات اساءت بسمعته
وبعلاقته بالمقربين منه سواء من عائلته او
من من اصدقائه نحن نعلم بان المحامي
اندروغرين كان قد سال الامير هاري خلال
المحاكمه بانه اذا ما كانت هذه الادعاءات
تستند الى تكهنات ام انها تستند الى ادله
فعليه ضد الصحيفه وبالتالي هذه هي المساله
الرئيسيه اما بالنسبه لمجريات المحكمه فقد
نحن نعلم بانها بدات الساعه التاسعه
والنصف صباحا الامير هاري يعني كان في
قاعه المحكمه لمده خمس ساعات او 6 ساعات
حتى تقريبا من عمليه استجواب تفصيليه
استندت الى بيان شهادته المكون من 55 صفحه
تستند الى اكثر من 30 مقاله اخباريه تم
تناول هذه المقالات يعني مقاله تلوى
الاخرى بشكل تفصيلي وطويل
بكل يعني مجريات وتفاصيل هذه الادعاءات
التي يعني قال الامير هاري بان المجموعه
استخدمتها في الحصول على معلومات الطرق
غير القانونيه التي قال هاري بان المجموعه
استخدمتها هي طبعا عبر التجسس على يعني
هواتفه او رسائله الصوتيه قال طبعا في بعض
المعلومات التي نشرتها الصحف بانها يعني
معلومات لا يمكن ان تكون قد شربت من القصر
بل انها يعني اما ان تكون قد يعني احدا ما
استمع مثلا الى رسائله الصوتيه او تجسس
على هواتفه قال ايضا بان المجموعه قامت
باستخدام او توظيف مثلا مح ققين
للحكم على معلومات بطرق غير قانونيه
بالاضافه طبعا الى نعم نعم ما المتوقع ان
يخرج عن هذه المحاكمه عروب وما الذي يريده
اصلا الامير هاري هل نتحدث فقط يعني عن
تعويض مادي يعني
ام ماذا
طبعا نحن نعلم بان الامير هاري يعني اخذ
على عاتقه تغيير المشهد الاعلامي لي
الصحافه البريطانيه وبالتالي هو ليس يعني
هو بخلاف اخيه ويليام نحن نعلم انا ويليام
كان قد توصل الى تسويه مع احدى الصحف بسبب
يعني قضيه مماثله لاختراق هاتفه ولكن
الامير هاري لا يبدو بانه وراء تسويه مع
الصحف التي يقاضيها هو يقاضي ثلاثه صحف
مجموعه مرر هي واحده من ثلاثه صحف يقاديها
في نفس الموضوع وهو يريد يعني ان يغير
الصحافه البريطانيه كما يقول كما انه يبدو
بانه يريد محاسبه المسؤولين الذين يعني
يلومهم بشكل كبير في وفاه والدته الاميره
الراحله ديانا بسبب يعني تجسسهم او بسبب
طبعا مضايقتهم مضايقتهم مضايقتهم لها قبيل
يعني
وبالتالي يعني الامير هاري يبدو مصمما على
انهاء هذه المحكمه لصالح اما بالنسبه
لردود الفعل من القصر اريد فقط ان اذكر
بان نحن نعلم بان الشعار القصر
ابدا ولا تشرح ابدا وبالتالي القصر لم يكن
له تعليق على هذه القضيه ولكن كان الملك
تشارلز كان يعني الامير هاري كشف ان الملك
تشارلز في وقت من الاوقات عندما ساله عن
قضيته عن القضيه التي يرفعها ضد الصحف قال
علق الملك تشارلز كان الامير تشارلز في
وقتها قال بان هذه هي يعني
عمليا انتحاريه يقوم بها الامير هاري في
رفع قضيه ضد الصحف شكرا جزيلا لك عروب عبد
الحق على كل هذه المعلومات مراسلات
العربيه من لندن
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم روسيا لا تستطيع الاعتراف
بطلبان حتى تكتفي بالتزاماتها في تشكيل
حكومه شامله التصريح هو لوزير الخارجيه
الروسي سرجا الذي كشف عن ان الاتصالات بين
موسكو وطالبان متواصله وشجعها على الاسراع
بحل المشكلات المعلنه للعالم اجمع لا يبدو
اذا ان طالبان ترقى لان تكون ورقه مناكفه
بين موسكو واوا لان الحركه الافغانيه حتى
الان تقدم ما يكفي كي يفكر اي طرف في
استخدامها كورقه اصلا
فيديو اليوم من خرسون الاوكرانيه فهناك
فرق متخصصه تكافح لانقاذ الحيوانات من
مياه الفيضانات بالطبع طال الضرر
الحيوانات الاليفه التي حوصرت داخل
المنازل وحتى الحيوانات البريه التي اضطرت
لهجري المخابيها الطبيعيه لكن في مثل هذه
الحروب يصبح مصير الحيوانات عرضا جانبيا
لان من فجر سد كخوفك لم يكترث اصلا بحياه
البشر
سرعه اليوم من الاكوادور الفيضانات قد
تكون في اي مكان وقد تحدث في سته انهار
وليس في واحد فقط لكنها بطبيعه الحال لن
تكون باهميه فيضان نهر اوكرانيا لان
الاقلام التي تكتب ليست مهتمه بالاكوادور
بهذا القدر لكن بعيدا عن الاقلام التي لا
تكتب كل شيء هناك اقلام تستحق البحث عنها
والمخاطره لانقاذها كهذا الطفل هو اقلام
دراسته
اذا انتهت مواضيع وملفات العربيه 360
ننتقل الان الى زميل صهيب واخبار الساعه
وملفات جديده مساء الخير يا صهيب مساء
الخير راويه نحن نترقب بعد قليل بدء جلسه
مجلس الامن الدولي التي عقدت او تعقد بطلب
من روسيا واوكرانيا بعد تفجير السد نوفاكا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات